as we look at the SP right now hovering
around 1900 mark where do you see it say
by December of this year personally I
december i don't know but i think
between now and the year end the market
will drop something like another ten
percent or even twenty percent i think
we can have a big sell-off in the fall
so a big sell-off coming this fall
you're predicting a loss of ten to
twenty percent a pretty significant
correction than mark well a lot of
stocks are bound 1026 already so i call
market value might've mark overall
market so the SP you think it could be
down ten to twenty percent let's put it
this way i think the xnc will close down
on the year and i think that the bull
market is more than five years old by
any standard this is the very old bull
market it began in march two thousand
and nine we're now august 2014 the
economic recovery decay it began in june
2009 we're now august 2014 is also by
any standard a lengthy economic recovery
a weak recovery largely courtesy of the
fed by printing money they have actually
delayed the cleaning process but i
believe that asset prices are
unattractive uh Nicole some shares I
hold some bomb I old some gold and gold
shares i own some real estate but i
don't believe that the returns will be
very high